all right so living with media queries
this is more about how we epi has first
of all I'm Alex Lee I work at Behance
now part of Adobe but we build so we
build
behance net to site with a lot of
creative portfolios and we're
essentially their showcase their
portfolios but we running the problem of
needing or wanting to showcase it in as
to as wide audience as possible which
means reaching out to all sorts of
devices all sorts of platforms so we
can't just have mobile apps which we do
have we also need the site to be
responsive and this we determined early
on the best way to do this is not to
have separate versions of the site for
every single devices coming out there
with way different sizes and formats and
all kinds of things the best way to do
this is just to have one site that is
going to respond and so we ran into some
challenges trying to try to get this to
happen and here's the the problems that
we came up with the first thing you
realize when you try to build a
responsive site is that if you have lots
of UI that you that your users are
interacting with but in order to
maintain the UI and have the UI display
when they should hide when they
shouldn't you have to have all these Dom
nodes on the page and then you're using
CSS media ya media queries in order to
hide and show these things as soon as
you have I don't know something like 50
different dialogues on the page every
just you just get rampant with these
style sheets and they just get out of
hand there's no way to fix that there's
also the problem of behavioral
divergence because we are a design
driven company as our founder would say
and what that really means is that the
design team design
some pretty outlandish behaviors for
when certain things start to behave
drastically differently so when you're
on the desktop everybody understands how
you use the website on the computer but
once you start shrinking down the form
factor you start shrinking down the
screen the website starts becoming very
different it has to behave differently
and I'll show you that some some of that
in a bit and then lastly the API Dom API
is uh difficult it's not the prettiest
thing in the world so we also wanted
something to hide developers it will
hide the Dom API from the developers so
here's an example
that's an awful resolution what you see
here is essentially the design for our
inbox this is a classic list of lists of
messages and a detail on the other side
so you have a master detail view pretty
understandable to everybody using a
desktop but yeah but then you get it
mobile Jesus there we go
so you get to the mobile view and it
becomes drastically different because
you start out on the left side this is
your landing page you land here and then
you have a list of things you have to
click on it to open it up you're able to
scroll through them but you have to
click on and open it up when you click
on and open it up it opens it up into
this view that takes over the entire
screen you have your UI completely
replaced with an X and then when you get
out of that ListView you have to go back
to the same scroll position as you were
before and if you're trying to do this
with CSS only you're gonna have a bad
time
where's my mouth so this is where we
started coming up with different
solutions for doing this the best thing
we have is an interaction breakpoint all
an interaction breakpoint is we are
separating logically what CSS sees as
breakpoints from what JavaScript sees as
breakpoints and the CSS world is way
more concerned about this fillet on the
JavaScript world we're less concerned
about display I'm more concerned about
at what points in the page do I need to
start behaving differently so that the
users interactions are consistent with
what their expectation is so when they
see something different they want to
they want to interact with it in a
different way as well so gonna need a
couple things for this you're gonna need
to know which media query you're
currently looking at you're gonna need
to know when you have entered and exit
different media queries and also you
need to be respond to all that and then
change the view accordingly and you want
to do that last bit the least do not
dumb as much as possible so okay so
that's how you would do it with a raw
Dom API with mass media mass media
returns you an object which has matches
it's a boolean about whether or not your
current media is matching the media
query is matching and it also has this
nice thing called add listener no note
that's AB listener and not add event
listener way to go down so that's
something that we have but that's kind
of tedious I don't want to have that all
over my code I don't want to have media
query stated all over my code I don't
want to copy that string everywhere so
what we did is we put it in our
essentially utility library layer every
DJ asked is something that we have it
provides an MVC layer utilities tools
great things for us so what we have is a
meet a media module and in the media
module you're stating as an object a
breakpoint name that matches onto a
media query so that when you're going
through this all that the rest
your code deals with is the breakpoint
name so for this we have to find phone
tablet and desktop and that is all that
we want to deal with in that helps you
just cut off everything else and think
about only things as being on the phone
or desktop or tablet and what that also
allows us to do is to provide a much
better interface for the events it will
when you cross boundaries of a media
query it will fire the enter or exit
events so that's what we did
oh also as a note this is all es6 now
it's not follow it get used to it
on the other side of it so we have hat
we have half the battle one which is how
to manage all the things that are
changing on the other side we have to
listen to what has changed and you know
provide the correct view for the user so
responsive entities is what we will came
up with and responsive entities they
need to be sensitive to media queries
but we should not the consumer of those
entities should not know about them at
all to the consumer of the entity they
are just dealing with any regular thing
that they won't render so here's what we
would like we would like just like that
when you saw the message from Eric I
said your work is tolerable one of my
favorite messages you construct a
message and you render that message
that's all you want to do that's all you
ever want to really deal with and you'll
note that there's nothing in here about
what break point you're at what media
queries you're dealing with all of that
is hitting away by the responsive entity
so this gives us a consistent interface
for how to deal with things then we have
to set up the breakpoints we're saying
okay you can use any arbitrary be
according here so you can do orientation
changes
then you get to the views so the views
are essentially encapsulations of the
view right the the encapsulation of all
the behavior that goes along with an
entity that means you can have
completely divergent markup completely
divergent behavior you can bind them all
together in one single one single entity
one single class that the object that
you throw around so you can have this is
template strings you can have template
strains template out things for you and
I didn't put it in here because it was
troublesome you can just find whatever
behave you you want in this we have our
own views but you can use backbone views
if you really if you have them so the
point at which it all comes back
together is the controller so in MBD we
have a responsive controller that all it
does is listen onto the media module
that I showed earlier and it bind onto
the media module and then listens for
changes as as those changes come along
but what you have is a nice statement
down here of what maps to what so in the
previous one we have shortened long as
different classes of views here we're
saying short and long match to certain
breakpoints so in the case where you are
at a vertical breakpoint you use the
short view when you're in the horizontal
breakpoint use the long view so that
frees us and that really cuts down at
the amount of different concerns at
every different level so that we have
really thin controllers mostly thin
views because man they want a lot of
interactions in those views and really
thin models so we like to keep
everything thin we don't mind having
more of everything just having thin
things also allows for better
reusability so here's the point where I
demoed this
and let me see if I can see this you can
also go to this on your phone to look at
it so this is gonna let me click using
their phones to look at this so I don't
so here is there we go so this this page
is the same code that I've had before
I'm see if I can show you what the code
behind it is like it's not gonna show me
the right thing but there it is the the
thing about this is I can rotate this to
simulate a orientation change and as
soon as I single out the orientation
change it changes the view and the code
that actually runs all of that is if I
can find it Yeah right here
I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't think that
people would want and want to zoom into
hello world so this is transpiled so
it's a little bit different but
essentially this is the same code that
you saw before you have a media
declaration you have the two different
views now you have a controller at the
bottom that binds them all together
finally at the bottom I don't know if
you can actually see that at the bottom
is where renders the thing where you
just create a message with the body
world and then it just renders it so
nice clean API for your responsive Java
scripting that's it that's it for me so
questions yes
yes mass media is the key that provides
all the functionality yet well you
wouldn't want but it's part of the Dom
API and it's difficult to manage right
it is supported on ok so the mass media
API for is supported on ie 10 and above
on i-89 you're able to get media queries
but the match media API is either
missing or wonky really strange yeah
there are polyfills the lucky thing for
us is that we have a great deal of
influence well because our audience is
wholly different our audience is very
much Safari Chrome Firefox so we can say
that for IE the section of IE that is
below 9 we're going to either partially
support or not really care about so yes
yes MBD gotcha ass is open source at
let's there we go oh by the way it's
that's where no big deal just saying
even the joyous party we don't take our
acronyms lightly at the answer this is
open source you can find it at that URL
or you know just search for Behance it's
one of our open source things no it does
not because es6 the ESX transpiler that
the one I was using is from square and
the transpiler I would only heard about
it way after Abby DJ's camera but I
would like to write a version for es6
except by the time that happens I will
need less than 50% of this library
because this provides promises but
promises now Firefox has native promises
so it's like why do I even need my own
code I don't really want it any other
questions